I've drawn an arbitrary
triangle right over here,
and I've also drawn its three
medians: median EB, median FC,
and median AD.
And we know that where the three
medians intersect at point G
right over here, we
call that the centroid.
What I want to do in this
video is prove to you
that the centroid is exactly 2/3
along the way of each median.
Or another way to
think about it,
we can pick any one
of these medians,
and let's say let's pick EB.
What I want to do
is I want to prove
that EG is equal to 2 times GB.
So whatever distance this is
it's twice this distance there.
Or another way to
think about it is EG
is 2/3 along the way of EB.
And the logic that I'm
using to prove this you
can use for any of
the medians to show
that the centroid is exactly
2/3 along the way of any median,
or divides it into
a segment that's
twice as long as
the other segment.
And to do that, let's focus--
I want to focus on triangle ABE
right over here.
And I'm going to draw this
median as essentially the base.
So let me draw it that way.
I'm going to try to
color code it similarly.
So we draw it a little
bit flatter than that.
So it's like that.
And then we have the
two yellow sides,
so it looks something like this.
It looks something like that.
And then we have the
centroid, right over here
at G. That is our
centroid, and then we
have this magenta
line going to A.
Let me draw it a little
bit neater than that.
We have that line
going to A, and then we
have this blue line going
to F right over here.
And let me label all the points.
Go back to the orange color.
So this is going to be
E, this is going to be B,
this is going to be A, this is
going to be F right over here.
And just to make sure we have
all the same markings, that
little marking there is that
marking, these two markings,
these two markings are on
this side right over there.
And the whole way that I'm
going to prove that EG is twice
as long as GB is just
refer to the result
that we did, I think,
a couple of videos
ago that the medians divide
this triangle into six smaller
triangles that all
have equal area.
So another way to think about
it is each of these three
small triangles have equal area.
These are three of the total
of six smaller triangles.
So these three all
have equal area.
So let's think about this
triangle right over here.
Let's think about this
triangle, triangle AGB.
This is triangle AGB
right over there.
Those are the same triangles.
And let's compare that to
triangle EAG right over here.
Let's compare it
to this triangle,
which is this triangle
right over here
on the original drawing.
Now, they both have
the exact same height.
If you view EG as their base--
or I the guess their shared
base, they don't have
the exact same base.
The smaller triangle
has the base E-- sorry,
the smaller orange triangle
has GB as it's base.
The larger blue triangle
has EG as its base,
but they definitely both have
the same height, or altitude,
when you draw it this way.
So their height, in both
cases, is this right over here.
Now the other thing
that we do know
is that this blue
triangle EAG has
twice the area of
the orange triangle.
How do we know that?
Because it's got two of
these triangles in it.
So one way to think about it
is if this orange triangle has
area x, actually let
me call it a-- well
I already used a, so I'm
going to call it area
x-- then each of these
blue triangles have area x.
Or you could say this entire
blue region has area 2x.
So if you look at this blue
triangle right over here,
we know that 1/2 times base
times height is equal to area.
So we get 1/2-- the base is EG.
1/2-- I'll do that
in the green color--
1/2 EG times height times
this yellow height is
going to be equal to 2x.
I'm just applying the formula
for area of a triangle.
1/2 base times height
is equal to area.
This is our area.
Now, let's do the same thing
for this orange triangle.
1/2-- let me scroll over a
little bit to the right--
we have 1/2 GB times
the yellow height is
going to be equal to x.
Well we can substitute it.
If this is equal to x, we can
place this entire expression
right over here for x.
So let's do that.
We get 1/2-- and
you might already
see where this is going, but
I won't skip any steps here--
we get 1/2 times EG times
h is equal to 2 times x.
But instead of x, I'm
going to write this here.
Is equal to 2 times 1/2
times GB times this length--
times the base of the
smaller triangle times h.
And now we can
just simplify this.
We have 2 times 1/2
is just going to be 1.
You can divide both
sides by h, and we
are left with 1/2
EG is equal to GB.
Or we could write EG
over 2 is equal to-- let
me do it in the same
color since I've
gone this far with
the same colors.
So we can write 1/2
EG is equal to GB.
And we're done.
This is essentially saying
that GB is half of EG.
So for example, if EG is
2, this is going to be 1.
If EG is 4, this
is going to be 2.
So we've actually
proven our result.
Well actually, let's
go back to-- this
is the result we
wanted to prove.
To get to there we just multiply
both sides of this equation
by 2.
You multiply this, the
left-hand side by 2, you get EG.
You multiply the right-hand
side by 2, you get GB.
So we've proven that
EG is twice GB .
And you can apply the same
logic to any of the medians
to show that the
centroid is exactly
2/3 along the way of the median.